Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute zeige ich euch ein schönes Brotrezept.
Das ist kein klassisches Brot sondern eins ohne Hefe.
Ich hab mir gedacht viele von euch haben jetzt grad keine Hefe da aber Backpulver habt ihr da!
Ich hab extra ne Umfrage gestartet und die meisten, ich glaub über 90% von euch
haben Backpulver zuhause.
Daher zeig ich euch jetzt das schnelle und einfache Rezept!
Für Backpulver braucht ihr auch keine Ruhzeit, also es ist auch wirklich sehr schnell.
Ich nehm jetzt erstmal mein Sieb und mein Mehl und jetzt sieb ich das in meine große Schüssel.
Und ich nehm heute Dinkelmehl Typ 630. Ihr könntet auch Weizenmehl nehmen, das ist auch kein Problem.
Wir wollen ja nichts verschwenden, Mehl ist nämlich ein Luxusgut!
(H *lacht*: Ja, vor allem heutzutage!)
So!
So, dazu geb ich jetzt Backpulver und auch das Salz, verrühre das ganz kurz miteinander
und dann hab ich hier noch die folgenden Zutaten:
Joghurt - wenn ihr jetzt keinen Joghurt habt, dann nehmt einfach Milch -
dann hab ich Mineralwasser mit Kohlensäure, so ein kleiner Geheimtipp
und etwas Öl und das verknete ich jetzt alles mit den Händen.
Ah und ein bisschen Essig weil wir ja keine Hefe haben, das gibt nochmal so
diesen sauren Geschmack.
So, den Teig dann auf der Arbeitsfläche weiterkneten. Nicht lange, grad so ne Minute
und wenn euch Mehl fehlt gebt auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen was dazu,
aber auch nur so viel, dass es gerade so nicht mehr klebt.
Und dann schnappen wir uns unsere Kastenkuchenform, besprühen die ordentlich mit Backtrennspray,
alternativ gerne Öl nehmen und dann den Boden mit einer Nusskernmischung ausstreuen.
Das ist zwar optional aber es ist einfach nur lecker!
So und jetzt geb ich den Teig einmal länglich da rein, drück ihn noch so ein bisschen flach oben.
Und jetzt schnappt ihr euch einfach Leitungswasser, gebt das oben drauf
und da kommt jetzt auch nochmal die Nusskernmischung oben drauf.
Und anschließend schneide ich mit dem Messer einmal in der Mitte ganz leicht ein bisschen was ein.
So und jetzt kommt unser Zauberbrot einfach in den vorgeheizten Backofen
- unteres Drittel, ganz wichtig! - 200 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze dass der Ofen schon ordentlich heiß ist.
Und dann backt ihr ihn so lange, bis er innen auch gar ist.
Falls er euch oben zu dunkel wird, einfach mit Alufolie abdecken und weiterbacken.
Und wir sehen uns dann nachher für den Anschnitt!
Nach 35min ist mein Zauberbrot jetzt fertig und jetzt stürze ich das einmal kurz solange es noch warm ist.
So! Ich zeig euch jetzt auch einen Trick, wie ihr erkennt - also generell - ob euer Brot durch ist.
Und zwar klopft ihr jetzt einfach auf die Rückseite.
Und wenn sich das hohl anhört, dann ist es durch.
(H: *kichert*)
Kann ja mal näher ran mit dem Mikro.
(H: Also wie mein Kopf!)
Genau! (lacht)
Und jetzt könnt ihr das luftdicht verpackt bis zu mehrere Tage lagern.
Es schmeckt auch lauwarm am allerbesten, da könnt ihr jetzt Butter und Käse und Wurst etc. drauf
geben und einfach nur genießen!
Ich hoffe, dass euch das Video gefallen hat,
macht's unbedingt nach!
(H: Und das ohne Hefe!)
Und das ohne Hefe! Also das muss man ja noch betonen, das sieht so hübsch aus!
Unbedingt nachmachen und ihr braucht summa summarum 40min mit Backzeit
und das ist echt super!
Also ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken und wir sehen uns bei meinem nächsten Rezept hier!
Tschüss!